yes christian you can see the federal
the fully federal building rather is
boarded up behind me
now this is just some of the precaution
that officials are taking as they
prepare for that potential
unrest across the country this coming
week
now this is the only building we can see
boarded up downtown so
far again the fully federal building is
protected both
with boards and with those fences ahead
of it
now the lloyd george courthouse across
the street appears to be operating as
normal at this time we did reach out to
the united states marshals for the
district of nevada
here's the statement they provided on
this quote the united states marshals
have since
1789 protected the federal judiciary we
will continue to take
needed steps to ensure that the
judiciary is able to carry out its vital
function in our state
we are taking the needed steps to
protect the judiciary as we prepare
for the presidential inauguration and a
peaceful transfer of power
as has been the tradition in our country
since it was founded end quote
now back out here live no word on
whether any other buildings in the area
plan to board up their windows ahead of
the inauguration
wednesday as i mentioned the loyd george
courthouse directly across the street
from the federal
the fully federal building here is
operating as normal boards that we can
see
but of course stay with eight news now
through the weekend and up until
wednesday
for the latest coverage on this here
locally we're now reporting live
downtown sasha loftis
8 news now